the past
two decades the cost of sequencing has
dropped dramatically
over here is a chart showing you how
much it costs to sequence one million
bases of dna
when the human genome project completed
in 2001 it cost
almost ten thousand dollars today we are
approaching
one cent to sequence a million bases of
dna which represents a one million fold
drop
in the cost of sequencing and if you
follow this chart you can see that there
are several inflection points in 2007
2010 and 2015 where prices had some
fairly steep crops
and these were largely driven by new
sequencing systems introduced by
illumina the dominant player in the next
gen sequencing market
on this slide are three different types
of sequencers from illumina they
actually have several more
but they really span the the scale of
sequencing that's being offered
on the left hand side is the aluminum
icy instrument in the middle is the
hi-seq
and on the right is the nova z the
newest high output sequencer from
illumina
and if we compare the output of these
machines and compare them with the
singer sequencing platforms we can see
just
how much more sequence we can generate
from these instruments if you just look
at how many reads you can get from a
single run
the mic generates 30 million reads the
hi-c generates three billion reads the
novaseq generates
13 billion reads while the singer
sequencing system
generates about 400 reads
and so it's a huge difference and if you
just look at this in terms of how much
sequence you can generate in a single
day
you can generate up to four trillion
bases on the novaseq
in one single day compared to 1 million
bases
on a traditional sinker instrument
illumina sequencing
is the dominant player in the market
it's an imaging based method
and generates many many reads millions
to billions of reads per run
and from each of these reads we can
generate 300 to 600 bases of sequence
it's really really accurate the error
rate is roughly 1
in 1 000 bases and with the new machines
we can actually sequence a human genome
for a thousand dollars
in less than 48 hours
[Music]
and the sequencing on these aluminum
platforms happens in flow cells these
are essentially microscope slides with
channels
on the inside what i have shown here is
a mysql cell next to a standard
eppendorf tube that's used for a lot of
lap work and these tubes are pretty
small about one and a half
inches in height and on this myc flow
cell we can generate about 1 to 30
million reads per run
[Music]
next up is the high seek flow cell you
can see it's quite a bit larger than the
mysql cell and this larger real estate
allows us to generate more reads in a
single run
approaching 3 billion reads and lastly
is the novice equal cell which is even
larger
and on this flow cell we can generate 13
billion reads
in a single run
so you can't just put dna into these
flow cells and get sequences out you
actually have to prepare your sample
and so there are several steps that
occur but basically what happens is you
take
your sample that you want to sequence
which is dna if you have something like
rna you can convert it with enzymes into
dna
you take that dna and then you have to
add on these adapter sequences at the
end
so in blue are primer binding sites that
allow the sequencing reaction to occur
this is similar to sanger sequencing
where we needed to have a primer bind
for dna polymerase
to move along the template dna and then
we also have these capture sequences
in green and orange and these allow
your sequencing sample to be captured
onto the flow cell for sequencing
once you have your dna sample prepared
it's a double-stranded molecule
which we denature and put into the flow
cell
and on the left-hand side again is a
picture of the high seek flow cell so
there are eight channels
and samples actually go into the glass
slide there are eight different channels
within there and
inside of the slide are a mixture
of short dna molecules
in orange and green and these orange and
green molecules will bind to both ends
of your sequencing library so we
denature our sample
flow those into the flow cell and they
can get captured by these primers
or these short dna molecules on the
surface of the slide
and once that occurs a dna polymerase is
added in the dna building blocks
introduced
and we copy that template and so we have
a newly synthesized strand
that's now physically constrained to the
bottom of the flow cell
we wash out the original template strand
and then allow the newly synthesized
strand to now bind
onto the other dna sequence present on
the surface in this case the orange
piece
and then we blow in some dna polymerase
and building blocks and we get another
strand formed
and we repeat this process many many
times and in the end we get about a
thousand copies
uh within a cluster and remember that
these thousand molecules all came from
the same
original template strand so they all
have the same sequence
we denature the strands and then we can
selectively cleave off one of the oligos
or the primers in this case the green
one
and we've washed those away so now all
the thousand molecules present
are all the identical strand because we
removed the other strand
we flow in a sequencing primer and now
the clustering process is complete
and this is the instrument that forms
clustering so first thing we do is we
take a brand new flow cell
again this is the size of a standard
microscope slide
and then we put it onto the stage of the
instrument
and the stage is a as a
region of the instrument that can
actually heat and cool to perform a lot
of the enzymatic reactions
next we load a blue plate of the
reagents that form the clustering
and lastly a strip tube with the eight
different samples that are going to be
loaded onto that flow cell
next a manifold is mounted on top of the
flow cell
and connected to the c-bot and in the
back of the c-bot or this clustering
instrument are a series of pumps
that will now pull reagents from the
blue reagent plates or from our sample
strip tube
and pass them through the flow cell and
this is how reagents
and liquids are delivered at this point
the clustering procedure
takes about three to four hours and once
that's done
we take that flow cell and move it onto
the actual sequencer in this case
a high seek instrument and on the high
sig instrument
we have a refrigerated compartment for
all the sequencing reagents
a lot of enzymes in there that need to
be kept cool during the three to four
day sequencing run
above the refrigerated section is a
series of pumps
that pull reagents from that
refrigerated compartment
and send them to the flow cell which we
will now
load onto the stage and so that is the
flow cell from the cbot
that just completed clustering this gets
mounted onto a stage
and locked in place and then we can
begin the sequencing run
and what that does is that will trigger
the pumps to start flowing
reagents from the refrigerator
compartment into the flow cell
and behind the flow cell is actually a
really powerful
microscope that is used to actually
sequence
each of those molecules of dna
and so remember that when we put the
flow cell onto the
sequencer this is what it looks like we
have a lot of clusters
that each have a sequencing primer bound
to them
and the chemistry for sequencing is very
similar to
the sanger sequencing terminators that
were used but the one difference is that
these are reversible
and so they're reversible in in two ways
so first
these can get incorporated into the
clusters by dna polymerase
and those clusters will light up in four
different colors depending on which base
gets incorporated
a picture is taken and after that
picture is taken we can actually remove
these terminators and the fluorescent
groups with some chemicals
and what results is we regenerate the
three prime hydroxyl group so now
that cluster can have another round of
bases added to it
and so this is what it looks like for a
single molecule
on this end over here we have our
template strand
bound to a sequencing primer and this
allows dna polymerase to bind
and then add a base in this case it's a
yellow one so once this gets added a
picture is taken
and then we add chemicals to remove the
fluorescent group
and the terminator so that dna plumes
can add a second base
an image is taken chemistry is performed
to remove that base
and to regenerate the three prime
hydroxyl and then we can add another
base
and so over time the cycle just repeats
over and over again
with multiple cycles of a base edition
imaging and then chemistry to remove the
blocks
and so if we look at take a look at this
depiction of five different cycles so
each of these
represents a different image taken and
if we follow
the top left and the bottom right
clusters and see how those colors
changes over time
we can actually build the sequence so
the top cluster the sequence is going to
be
a g cct because it goes from yellow blue
red red green and the bottom one is
gtaac
and so again the power of the system is
that you can sequence up to billions of
sequences
at the same time in parallel and this is
what gives these instruments their
throughput
so some people ask me why can't we
increase the amount of
bases that we get in a single read by
just repeating the chemistry over and
over again
do this a thousand two thousand ten
thousand times
and the main reason why is that the
enzymes and chemistries aren't perfect
so over here i have a cluster of one
single cluster
made out of the same template molecules
but what happens is
because chemistry isn't perfect some of
the strands lag behind so this one is a
yellow instead of a green
and some clusters jump ahead so this one
is now a red
instead of a green because it hopped
ahead and what happens is
these errors aren't too bad but over
time and many many cycles over the
course of 100
200 300 cycles more and more strands
start to lag
and more start to jump ahead so that
your true signal starts to disappear
and gets weaker and weaker and this
really limits the limit of sequencing to
about 300 bases
for each read so with the
illumina sequencer four different images
are taken during each cycle one for each
of the four color
bases and so the images
actually look like this they're not very
clear they're not perfect circles
and they're very difficult to to see by
eye to
figure out where one cluster starts and
another begins
you know one example is here let's say
in the first cycle we have two clusters
that are about g
these just look like a single blob
that's a single color and this is really
hard for the sequencer to pick out
but because we're sequencing many many
sequences at a time in parallel
chances are these aren't identical
sequences and if we go through another
cycle
you know chances are that they'll have a
difference so now this cluster on the
right
is an a while the cluster on the left is
still a g
but because of this the sequencer can
now compare these images
and determine where cluster a has a very
pure signal
where there's a mixture between cluster
a and b
and where cluster b has a pure signal
and it'll decide to just take
imaging information from just these
clean
areas where they have very pure signal
so again this is four color chemistry
from illumina this is what had been used
for
for many many years and it was very
clear and obvious one color for each of
the four bases
but there are issues with this so the
colors depicted here
you know you can tell the colors are
very very different however if you
actually look at the emission spectra
you can see there's significant overlap
between the four colors
and this requires the instruments to
undergo a lot of color compensation and
this can contribute to errors
so a few years ago illuminate introduced
two color chemistry
so instead of using four colors to
represent four bases they're now using
two colors to represent four bases in
this case they're using red and green
and the way this works is that you have
uh t's which are green
cs which are red a's which are actually
a mix of both colors so you'll see them
in both images and then gs actually have
no color or no signal
and so this is how you can encode uh
four different bases with only two
colors
and so initially the quality of the two
color chemistry wasn't as great as the
four color chemistry but recent
developments on the novaseq platform one
of
lumina's newer sequencers that uses two
colors the data quality actually rivals
the four color instruments
and so there's definitely been some
improvements in this area the other
benefit of two color sequencing is that
these reagents are generally cheaper to
make because you don't have to have as
many colors
and the instruments are also less
expensive because you only have to
capture
two images instead of four so how far
can you take this
can you do sequencing with only a single
color and the answer is yes
a newer platform just released by
illumina uses a single color
to encode four different bases and they
do this by
taking two images that are separated by
a chemistry step
in the middle so i'll walk you through
this in the first image
they add the four different bases and in
this case the a's
and t's have a color on there and again
it's the same color
the c's and g's don't have any color one
thing to note is the a base has
a cleavable linkage between the base
and the color and the c base has
a molecule that we can use to attach
something later on so we take an image
first so a's will have color and t's
will have color c's and g's will not
have any color
next we go through a chemistry step that
will cleave
the green color from the a bases and
it'll add a molecule that will bind to
the sea bases
and make them now colored and so we take
a second image so in the second image
a's won't have any color because any
that did had them cleaved off
the g still won't have any color but
both the c's and t's will have color
and what this looks like if you break
this down is if you compare
a single cluster and look at its color
whether it's on or off between image one
or two
you can get four different bases out
so these are the different flavors of
limited sequencing we started off with
four color chemistry
moved to two color chemistry now we have
one color chemistry
all these chemistries are still used
currently on existing platforms and each
of them have
have their benefits
you